die MSC meraviglia
zu machen
die MSC meraviglia ist eines der größten
Schiffe europäischer
Kreuzfahrtgesellschaften
316 m lang 43 m breit und
schwindelerregende 18 Decks hoch
auf dem Heck gibt es einen Wasserpark
und einen Hochseilgarten
[Musik]
über der 80 Meter langen innenpromenade
die sich über zwei Decks erstreckt
prangt der größte led-himmel der
Weltmeere ein anderes Highlights
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als Kapitän Raffaele Ponte Corvo seine
Arbeit bei der mediterranian shipping
company begann war die
Containerschifffahrt noch das
Hauptgeschäft der Reederei 1990 gehörte
erst zur Besatzung des ersten
Passagierschiffs der MSC das immer noch
im letzten Jahrhundert
nun ist die meraviglia sein Leben er
führt dieses brandneue Kreuzfahrtschiff
von 1500 Besatzungsmitgliedern
zu den italienischen Hafenstädten Neapel
und Messina
von dort folgt ein Abstecher nach Malta
und ein Tag auf hoher See bis die Reise
schließlich in Barcelona endet
früh morgens muss der Kapitän
ich bin 60 Minuten
Spielraum haben
dann müssen sie einen guten Kilometer
rückwärts fahren mit nur 50 m Platz zu
den Pierce um dann anzulegen
[Musik]
ohne seine Offiziere könnte der Kapitän
ein derart komplexes Anlegemanöver nicht
bewerkstelligen
[Musik]
zu werden
dort kommt die ausgeklügelte Steuerung
zum Einsatz
zwei unterschiedlich ausgerichtete
port-antriebe das Heck des Schiffes der
Bug ist dabei der Drehpunkt
vitana wie sieht's bringen genug
Werts durch den schmalen Kanal zu
manövrieren
könnte
Windows der Wind ist unser Gegner
45 Minuten nach der Einfahrt in den
Hafen
als würde er einen Minibus einparken
manchmal fällt mir nicht wirklich
leichter als mein Auto warten
nun ist Eile geboten
wir arbeiten von 7:30 Uhr bis 16:30 Uhr
wie viele LKW mit Obst und Gemüse wurden
schon entladen
[Musik]
gebracht werden
normalerweise sind es 16 bis 17 LKW die
alleine 45 Tonnen Obst und Gemüse
liefern
verlassen mehr als 4000 Passagiere das
Schiff für einige ist es das Ende ihrer
einwöchigen Reise für andere geht es nur
auf einen Tagesausflug
die meisten Kreuzfahrten beginnen und
enden für alle Passagiere im gleichen
Hafen doch bei dieser Reise kann man in
jedem Hafen ein bzw auschecken
unglaublich toll
[Musik]
1200 Balkonkabinen
wer ist etwas geräumiger mag dem könnte
eine der 8 Mais mit zwei Etagen gefallen
Schlafzimmer oben und Wohnzimmer unten
zudem gibt es zwei wellness-suiten mit
Heimtrainer direkt im Zimmer
um 10:30 Uhr sind die meisten der 16 LKW
schon vor Ort
[Musik]
es fehlt ein LKW dessen Ladung unbedingt
für das Buffet benötigt wird
[Musik]
einige Lebensmittel brauchen wir
dringend Essen
die sollten eigentlich schon da sein
wenn das Chef anlegt
im Hafen von Genua ist food and beverage
Manager Massimo lazari auf der Suche
nach einem LKW
wir brauchen unbedingt
[Musik]
es ist schon nach 10:30 Uhr
für das heutige Mittagsbuffet benötigt
wie viele sollten denn noch kommen
bleibt der Kombüse kaum genug Zeit um
das Obst und das Gemüse zu waschen
zuzubereiten und anzurichten
was haben sie geladen
die andere Ware
hierher geschickt
[Musik]
danke
endlich habe ich ihn gefunden
über die nächsten Stunden starten sich
die Gäste schon mal für die anstehende
Reise
[Musik]
an Bord herrscht schon reger Betrieb
um 17 Uhr heißt es dann alleine los
[Musik]
die meraviglia
mit all ihren Annehmlichkeiten
[Applaus]
abends wird ausgiebig gefeiert
[Musik]
und morgens entspannt oder trainiert
am zweiten Tag
nähert sich die MSC meraviglia dem Hafen
von Neapel
Kapitän
seine Heimatstadt liegt nur 90 Minuten
Autofahrt entfernt
an Bord geholt
haben
[Musik]
nach dem Smalltalk wird es ernst
Windgeschwindigkeit
16 Knoten an Steuerbord
vier Länge 390 m maximal
[Musik]
zu bewegen
diesmal kommen jedoch auch zwei
Bugstrahlruder zum Einsatz um den Bug
Richtung Backbord zu drücken
er dreht die merabilia
ca 25
gelegt haben
sind die Gruppen vom Yachtclub bereit es
fehlen also noch rund 30 Leute
Bescheid
ab dann voll Pompeii
vier privat Touren für VIP Passagiere
und ein yachtausflug für die 300 Gäste
die zur Insel Capri übersetzen wollen
pünktlichen Abfahrt
um 17:30 Uhr
zurück zumindest diejenigen die in der
Umgebung
einige der Touren die weiter weg führten
bereiten cartersen ja noch
Kopfzerbrechen
10 Minuten
auf einen Mann gerichtet Gianluca
Evangelista
[Musik]
aktuell
es ist 19:20 Uhr im Hafen von Neapel die
MSC meraviglia soll laut Plan in 10
Minuten ausschlafen
[Musik]
meistens liegt es am
verkehrungen bedeuten einen höheren
Treibstoffverbrauch um pünktlich am
nächsten Hafen zu sein
volle Fahrt geht es aufs Meer hinaus
auf Sizilien um am Morgen des dritten
Tages in den Hafen von Messina
einzulaufen
auf der Brücke herrscht
Alarmbereitschaft der stellvertretende
Kapitän
könnte
man kann nicht einfach abbremsen
[Musik]
doch heute ist in der Straße von Messina
kaum was los
mit Hilfe der Hafenlotsen steuert der
Kapitän die meraviglia routiniert in den
Hafen und an den Pia
1 0 0
[Musik]
ach dann an Brücke
haben wir 35 bis 40 m Spielraum
zu einem Kriegsschiff hält das am Bier
liegt
genug Platz schauen sich
der Lotse glaubt dass die beiden Schiffe
jede Sekunde kollidieren werden
und alles zahlen
heute bestätigen
Punkt
nur 15 Minuten nach Beginn der Drehung
alles in Ordnung
liegt Ponte Corvo wie geplant am Pier an
danke
während die Gäste auf Erkundungstour
gehen
[Musik]
da ist noch Klebeband von der
Ausstellung dran
[Musik]
auch im Wasserpark gibt es was zu tun
wenn Sie hier ausrutschen besteht
Verletzungen
[Musik]
auch an einem nagelneuen Schiff nagt
schnell der Zahn der Zeit
solche Stellen
die Mauro hat ein Auge für Detail
Kleinigkeiten können ganz schnell groß
werden
um im Maschinenraum nach dem Rechten zu
sehen
das ist ein neuer Motortyp
ie
elektrischen Generatoren erzeugen mehr
als 67.000 Kilowatt Leistung
damit könnte man eine ganze Stadt
versorgen und genau das ist die
meraviglia auch mit ihren vielen
kombüssen Restaurants Pools und
Gemeinschaftsbereichen
Bewegung versetzen
heute gibt es ein Problem
ein Kratzer den müssen wir
rausschmeckern
eine Rolle
[Musik]
all diese Inspektionen Ausbesserungen
und Reparaturen durch die 1500 köpfige
Besatzung halten das Schiff am laufen
die Gäste bekommen davon gar nichts mit
es ist wie bei einer gelungenen
Theatervorstellung der viele Proben
vorangehen und auch die wird geboten
[Musik]
es ist kurz vor 7 Uhr morgens am vierten
Tag der Kreuzfahrt auf der MSC
meraviglia
über Nacht hat die meraviglia die
Strecke von Sizilien bis zur
maltesischen Hauptstadt Valletta
zurückgelegt
direkt hintereinander fahren
dann können
150 Steuerbord
die größten gefahrenlauern unter Wasser
denn die meraviglia hat fast 9 m
Tiefgang links und rechts der
kanalmarkierungen könnte der Ozean Riese
aufgrund laufen
Meldung an Brücke wenn das Verkehr
t nach Valletta ist ein absolutes
Highlight
eine wunderschöne
Geschichte die man sieht und spürt
el
500 Jahre alt
[Musik]
wurden sie aufwändig restauriert
dabei wurde der uralte Kalkstein von
Pflanzen Bewuchs und Verschmutzungen
befreit
okay
[Musik]
Proben unten auf der X7 am Heck des
Schiffs Tänzer und Akrobaten für die
Premiere einer brandneuen Show des
weltberühmten Cirque du Soleil
okay
hier herrschen andere Voraussetzungen
als in den Himmel hohen Zirkuszelten und
Theatern in denen die Artisten sonst
Auftreten
in mancher Hinsicht heraus
wegen der geringen Raumhöhe musste ich
mir was neues ausdenken
Punkt die Seitenbänder
normalerweise bewegen
war auch für die Artisten anfangs
ungewohnt
während der konzeptionphase muss ich bei
der Planung
bewegt
das möchte um damit zu arbeiten
[Musik]
in der Kombüse haben der
stellvertretende Küchendirektor Pasquale
zu tun
Sie bereit
[Musik]
wir Frittieren
Lachs mit Mangocreme und Gerste
süß salzig scharf ein Geschmackserlebnis
[Musik]
se raus
sie wandeln durch das antike von Mauern
umgebene Medina und bewundern die reich
verziertesten
oder sie spazieren durch die Kassen von
Valletta und genießen das Flair der
malerischen Stadt
um 17:30 Uhr
gleich werden die Leinen eingeholt
guten Abend
schaut bei jedem der fünf Spezialitäten
Restaurants vorbei die an der Promenade
von 666
den kleinen Medium groß zu Hause
[Musik]
okay los wie viele
pushen die Kellner durch die Lounge
[Musik]
währenddessen bereiten sich die Artisten
auf die uhraufführung ihrer neuen Show
Sonor vor
nach knapp einer Stunde muss nur noch
der Nachtisch serviert werden
der Hammer
wie viele
[Musik]
Premiere
von vorne
auf hoher See
[Musik]
es ist der vierte Abend an Bord der MSC
meraviglia
[Musik]
und seiner neuen Show Sonor
a
doch der Sound ist längst nicht alles
wir haben jede Menge Spielzeuge z.B die
große aufklappbare Treppe
in der Beschichtung
[Musik]
wir haben ein Karussell setzen
ganzen schweren und großen Einbauten
müssen auch Stürme und schwere See
überstehen
[Musik]
die Zuschauer verschwenden sicher keine
Gedanken an diese technischen Details
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am nächsten Morgen beginnt für die Gäste
der MSC meraviglia ein ganzer Tag auf
hoher See
es geht von Malta nach Barcelona
für den Hotelmanager Giuseppe Panne und
sein Team gilt es heute 4000 Gäste an
Bord zu unterhalten
und alles hier passiert
es gibt nur das Schiff das Meer und die
Passagiere das muss alles viel
geschmiert laufen
auf dem Oberdeck des Schiffs legt beaven
Williams
für den spektakulären Hochseilgarten
Himalayan Bridge Brücke des Himalaya
meistens sind 100 Leute gleichzeitig im
Hochseilgarten
einige kriegen Angst andere drehen
gleich drei oder vier Runden
wer etwas Abkühlung braucht genehmigt
sich einen Drink
[Musik]
Becher auf der Promenade unter der LED
Kuppel
oder tobt sich im Wasserpark aus
ziehen
das sind unsere drei rutschen
[Musik]
nach 24 Stunden auf See sind Kapitän
Ponte Corvo und sein Team am nächsten
Morgen früh auf der Brücke die Einfahrt
in den Zielhafen steht bevor Barcelona
alles gut
gut oder
in der Arena
-antrieben drehen
wir gehen rüber
manövrieren
doch es gibt ein Problem
die Steuerung in der backbordnock
funktioniert nicht
ich sehe dich nicht stören
[Musik]
von der Mitte der Brücke auf die
backbordnock umzuschalten
[Musik]
was zuerst nach einem Kinderspiel
aussahung
droht zu einem riskantenmanöver zu
werden
die MSC meraviglia muss im Hafen von
Barcelona gedreht werden
doch die zum Anlegen notwendige
Steuerung ist ausgefallen
die Brücke hat drei Steuerungen eine in
der Mitte eine in der backbordnock und
eine in der Steuerordnung
und jetzt
nichts
steuern da er von dort aus freie Sicht
auf den Pier hat
jetzt funktionieren nur noch die
Steuerungen in der Mitte und in der
Steuerordnung doch von diesen beiden
Positionen ist seine Sicht extrem
eingeschränkt
er muss eine Entscheidung fällen
gemeinsam überlegen der Kapitän und der
hafenlotse wie Sie am besten vorgehen
langsam rückwärts das funktioniert
rückwärts Steuern
Problem ist
etwas mehr Abstand
[Musik]
jetzt ganz langsam
die Steuerung zu reparieren doch so
einfach ist das nicht
neu starten
[Musik]
wir versuchen 50 m Abstand zu den
Schiffen zu halten
vorbei hier ist auf steuern
[Musik]
jetzt kommt seine ganze Erfahrung zum
Tragen
[Musik]
knapp eine Stunde nach dem Ausfall der
Steuerung in der backbordnoc
fast den Positionen Maschinen
großartig
wir wussten dass du das tun ich in
diesem Fall erstmal nichts mehr gesehen
[Musik]
die Ingenieure machen sich sofort daran
den Defekt zu beheben
die Stromversorgung des steuerpuls war
unterbrochen
die Gäste gehen von dort um Barcelona zu
erkunden
[Musik]
von denen Schwierigkeiten auf der Brücke
haben sie nichts mitbekommen
dasselbe gilt für die meisten Arbeiten
und Anstrengungen die die Crew der MSC
meraviglia auf dieser Kreuzfahrt
unternommen hat
bei uns nicht gut genug
die MSC meraviglia ist wie ihr Name
schon sagt ein Wunder ein Wunder der
Technik und der Organisation das Wetter
heute
ich kann mir keinen besseren Job
vorstellen wir dürfen die ganze Welt
bereisen und haben Menschen an Bord die
Ihre schönste Zeit des Jahres ihre Haare
verdiente Urlaubszeit bei uns verbringen
[Musik]
die Besatzung der MSC meraviglia ist
stolz auf ihr Schiff und ihre
anspruchsvolle Aufgabe
sie setzen
[Musik]